madame la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
madame la première ministre à travers
votre nomination c'est une certaine idée
de la république qui s'incarne et dans
laquelle peuvent je le crois se
reconnaître largement les parlementaires
au delà de leurs convictions et de leur
engagement
une république du travail celui qui a
permis votre parcours une république de
l'engagement celui qui dans toutes vos
fonctions n'a jamais cessé de vous
animez une république de l'égalité
celles qui s'adressent à toutes les
petites filles de notre pays
c'est donc avec beaucoup d'émotion que
je prends la parole après vous sous
l'oeil bienveillant de la première femme
élue à la présidence de l'assemblée
nationale
ce sont encore deux femmes qui me
succéderont dans cette tribune quel
symbole au regard de l'histoire de
france tes combats qui nous ont précédés
au regard du mépris et des quolibets
conduit ici supporter tant de femmes
parlementaires et ministres le temps des
femmes est venu et c'est historique le
temps des fermes est venu et il durera
soyez
soyez assurés que nous saurons usé de
nos nouvelles responsabilités avec
bienveillance mais surtout avec
pugnacité ce qui nous intéresse ce n'est
pas d'être les premières mais bien de
nous inscrire dans le temps long
madame la première ministre vous venez
de nous exposer la feuille de route que
vous fixé à votre gouvernement il me
revient en tant que présidente du
principal groupe de notre assemblée de
préciser nos intentions et l'état
d'esprit qui nous anime alors même que
nos concitoyens s'interroge et c'est
bien légitime sur la capacité qui sera
la nôtre majorité et opposition à
adapter les pratiques parlementaires à
la nouvelle donne politique que les
français ont choisi nous sommes
collectivement dépositaire d'un héritage
la constitution de la vème république
je m'inscris avec l'ensemble des députés
de mon groupe dans cette fidélité
fidélité à celui qui l'a inspiré le
général de gaulle
fidélité à ce qu'ils ont fait évoluer
jacques chirac et lionel jospin et
nicolas sarkozy
fidélité au subtil équilibre des
pouvoirs que notre texte fondamental
pose un président légitime un
gouvernement qui a les moyens d'agir une
assemblée nationale ayant la capacité à
légiférer en toute liberté voilà le
cadre notre cadre commun non pas le
blocage non validé bien peu républicaine
que les résultats des élections sont
faits pour être contesté dans la rue
mais cette vème république
mais cette vème république qui nous fait
qui nous tient et que dans cette
majorité présidentielle nous voulons
faire vivre face au temps présent nous
aurons à le faire évoluer de nouveau
dans son usage car les attentes de nos
concitoyens sont fortes sur leur
association au processus de décision
notamment mais évoluer ce n'est pas
déconstruire améliorer ce n'est pas
trahir le sens des intentions des
constituants de 1958 et le débat que
nous avons aujourd'hui nous offre
l'opportunité de clarifier te définir un
cap et un chemin que les opposants
acharnés à la vème république s'en
offusque rien de plus normal ils sont
dans leur rôle mais que des
représentants de partis de gouvernement
qui ont exercé le pouvoir en respectant
cet esprit de notre constitution
feignent de s'en indigner voilà qui est
plus surprenant
la vème république il y a ceux qui
veulent l'abattre et ceux qui veulent la
faire vivre pleinement nous sommes de
ceux ci nos institutions constituent le
socle de notre action elles sont bien au
delà des bancs de la majorité
présidentielle notre bien commun
les 10 et 24 avril puis les 12 et 19
juin les français ont fait leur choix le
choix d'un président fort largement
réélu et pour la première fois hors
cohabitation
le choix le choix d'un parlement fort
non seulement où les lois ce vote mais
où elle s'élabore il n'ya pas les
français qui votent bien et ceux qui
votent mal il y a le choix des français
et de ce choix souverain nous sommes
collectivement dépositeurs
d'abord en méthode en faisant davantage
de place à la délibération collective
qui est le socle de notre pacte
démocratique aller coûte aux débats aux
négociations en faisant émerger une
culture du compromis
il faudra mieux associer les
parlementaires en amont il faudra revoir
la fréquence d'examen des textes de loi
car comme le dit le conseil d'état quand
la loi est bavarde le citoyen ne lui
prenne plus qu'une oreille distraite
moins de loire mieux écrites mieux
négocier mieux évaluer pour améliorer
concrètement la vie des français voilà
notre objectif
il faudra rééquilibrer l'initiative
parlementaire entre propositions et
projets de lois et notre groupe il
veillera à tout cela nous sommes prêts
et j'y suis prête
le choix des français commandent ensuite
que nous rassemblions une majorité
autour d'un grand dessein capable de
rassembler au delà de la majorité
présidentielle tous ceux qui ayant fait
d'autres choix ou s'étant abstenus se
reconnaissent dans l'idée républicaine
non pas une république inerte qui à
force d'immobilisme fini par se
recroqueviller mais une république
d'action qui retrouve sa capacité à
changer la vie
le compromis je le dis clairement c'est
partager un même objectif est de trouver
un accord sur les moyens d'y parvenir et
quand cela se fait cela doit se faire
dans la transparence
sans rien cacher de ses intentions
rechercher des compromis c'est la nature
même du travail parlementaire c'est la
capacité à enrichir notre projet le
compromis oui la compromission jamais
la situation nous invite à une forme de
renaissance républicaine cela tombe bien
nous sommes profondément républicain est
l'objectif d'une renaissance de nos
politiques et de nos pratiques c'est ce
qui justifie l'existence même de notre
groupe ce qui fait sa cohérence ce qui a
réuni des femmes et des hommes qui n'ont
pas tous les mêmes parcours politique ou
personnel mais qui ont décidé de
s'engager la renaissance s'est donné un
autre modèle les moyens d'agir cette
renaissance doit se traduire en actes
nous sommes conscients de l'ampleur de
la tâche qui est la nôtre nous savons
ici que nous formons une assemblée élue
par une minorité des lectrices et des
lecteurs
la vérité nous impose de dire ici
qu'aucun des groupes de notre assemblée
aucune des coalitions déclaré ne peut
revendiquer en conscience d'avoir obtenu
la pleine et entière confiance des
français
en revanche par leur abstention comme
par leur vote nos compatriotes nous ont
placés chacun au pied du mur ils nous
ont donné mandat pour agir pour trouver
les voies pour que le pays avance ils
ont formulé une exigence dont nous
devons nous montrer dignes pour mériter
leur confiance
quel constat pouvons nous porter
aujourd'hui les grands principes que
notre république a formulé installé
concrétiser sur lesquels se sont
construites les oppositions les plus
fortes font désormais l'objet d'un large
consensus il faut s'en réjouir plus
personne ou presque ne remet en cause le
principe de l'éducation gratuite et
universelle du droit à l'accès à la
santé du droit à la sécurité
plus personne ou presque ne remet en
cause la nécessité d'agir pour lutter
contre l'ampleur du dérèglement
climatique et pour nous préparer aux
effets inéluctables des changements en
cours mais derrière ce relatif consensus
sur les enjeux il y à la réalité celles
vécues par nos concitoyens qui justifie
des réformes des décisions la réalité
d'une école qui trop souvent encore
malgré l'engagement de ses acteurs et
les moyens qui lui sont consacrés
reproduit les inégalités
la réalité des déserts médicaux et des
difficultés d'accès aux soins partout
sur notre territoire malgré
l'application admirable de nos soignants
et les efforts considérables engagés au
cours des dernières années la réalité
d'une insécurité qui minent la vie
quotidienne des français les plus
vulnérables des quartiers de nos villes
mais aussi de nos villages malgré le
professionnalisme de nos forces de
l'ordre et l'augmentation des moyens de
la police et de la justice la réalité
d'un système de retraite par répartition
qui est notre patrimoine commun mais
demande à être garantis dans la durée
qui doit intégrer la nécessité de faire
progresser les petites retraites et nous
laisser les marges de manoeuvre
indispensable pour faire face au défi du
grand âge la réalité d'un système social
qui figurent parmi les plus
redistributif au monde mais qui
n'empêche pas la peur du déclassement ou
la crainte de ne pas réussir à boucler
la fin du mois
la réalité aussi des contraintes
nouvelles liées aux changements
nécessaires à la lutte pour le climat
synonyme de dépenses nouvelles de
changement d'habitudes de bouleversement
de nos modes de production et de
consommation d'une remise en cause de
nos sources d'énergie les français
n'attendent pas seulement que nous
protégions des institutions ou des
services publics qui fondent notre pacte
républicain
il nous faut les consolider et donc les
rebâtir assurer leur renaissance cette
renaissance nécessitera des
investissements nouveaux et donc de
conserver une économie en croissance
parce que précipiter notre pays dans la
crise par des décisions déraisonnables
et des dépenses sans contrainte ce
serait faire porter à nos entreprises
des charges insupportables au prix de la
baisse de leur compétitivité
ce serait abdiquer notre objectif de
plein emploi ce serait appauvrir les
français et ce serait in fine et obérer
la capacité de l'état à faire face à ses
responsabilités
pas d'augmentation de la dette pas
d'augmentation des impôts voilà le seul
cadre responsable dans lequel nous
pouvons mener notre action
la renaissance que nous portons imposera
que soit protéger le pouvoir d'achat
et donc de poursuivre le travail entamé
pour une fiscalité allégée
trop d'impôt tué l'impôt et on ne combat
pas l'inflation en l'alimentant
souvenons nous des mots si juste de
pierre bérégovoy
la renaissance que nous voulons
contribuer à faire émerger exigera que
soient préservées les générations
futures donc de tenir l'objectif d'une
dette publique continue je suis réduite
donc de continuer à renforcer notre
europe une europe plus forte et plus
souveraine pour résister aux nouveaux
empires et aux nouveaux défis
environnementaux technologiques
sanitaire migratoires qui ne connaissent
pas les frontières
la présidence française de l'union
européenne a démontré notre capacité
d'action collective sous l'impulsion du
président de la république taxe carbone
aux frontières régulation des grandes
plateformes numériques et solidarité
indispensable avec le peuple ukrainien
qui lutte pour sa liberté
quelle émotion de voir le drapeau
européen entré au coeur du parlement
ukrainien à l'opposé de ceux qui
voudraient y s'il en chasse et je suis
fier de m'exprimer devant lui
je suis fier de m'exprimer devant lui il
est aussi notre héritage et une part
indispensable de notre avenir la
renaissance républicaine enfin passe par
la réaffirmation de la laïcité comme
fondement de notre bien commun par la
capacité à faire renaître le goût du
métier pour des enseignants qui se
sentent déconsidérés en tant que figure
d'autorité et finissent par se sentir
insécurisés et je vous parle ici en tant
qu élu d'un département qui a connu les
froids avec la décapitation de samuel p
tit
re naissance par le refus acharné les
discriminations comme des assignations d
enfermement identitaire par la passion
de l'égalité entre les territoires entre
les citoyens par la défense de nos
libertés publiques comme de la liberté
d'entreprendre par les opportunités
offertes de s'extraire de sa condition
de naissance ou d'avoir un
accompagnement digne des personnes
dépendantes ou handicapées par la
culture pour tous
condition évidente est nécessaire de
l'émancipation
à chaque fois madame la première
ministre que votre gouvernement
sollicitera notre assemblée pour mettre
en oeuvre des politiques publiques
répondant à ces objectifs vous serez
pouvoir compter sur le soutien plein et
entier des députés de notre groupe ces
réformes à venir c'est loin à rédiger à
amender cette action de l'état a évalué
les groupes de la majorité devront les
aborder en tenant compte de la nouvelle
donne politique de l'assemblée issue des
urnes le 19 juin dernier donc avec de
nouvelles pratiques donc avec un nouvel
objectif celui de concourir à une forme
de renaissance démocratique
après tout nous ouvrir aux autres
intégrer les points de vue d'autrui sans
préjuger de leur origine dès lors
qu'elles se situent dans l'arc
républicain
préféré le consensus sur les projets aux
postures sur les idéologies c'est dans
l'adn du mouvement que nous avons bâtie
avec le président de la république et
qui justifie notre engagement
la co construction des textes
législatifs avec le gouvernement fut
déjà une réalité lors de la précédente
législature
sans doute de là vont pas nous assez
revendiquer et je veux ici rendre
hommage à nos prédécesseurs et notamment
à celles et ceux auxquels le sort
électorale a été défavorable il ne
méritait pas
il ne méritait pas cette image injuste
de députés playmobil que certains se
sont appliqués à leur a collé c'était
injuste tout simplement parce que
c'était faux
ces défauts oui mais cela ne doit pas
nous empêcher d'être encore plus
déterminés en étant par exemple plus
imaginait-il fait plus audacieux dans
notre pratique des prérogatives du
contrôle du parlement
notre présidente de l'assemblée
nationale a proposé des pistes pour
améliorer l'efficacité de notre travail
collectif je souhaite que nous on saisit
son ensemble au delà de nos groupes
respectifs de même que je saisirai les
membres de mon groupe afin que nous
adoptions pour nous-mêmes de nouvelles
formes de fonctionnement qui
contribueront à une renaissance de notre
démocratie parlementaire par une
capacité à travailler davantage avec nos
collègues des autres groupes politiques
en réinterrogeant par exemple la
question déco signature de propositions
de loi ou d'amendements avec des députés
d'autres groupes de l'arc républicain ce
débat nous l'aurons et nous le
trancherons
cette volonté de renaissance
démocratique n'est ni une fin en soi ni
une simple réponse à un équilibre
politique inédit de notre assemblée elle
figurait dans le projet présidentiel au
travers de l'annonce d'une nouvelle
méthode de gouvernement avec un but
précis elle doit nous permettre
d'élaborer et d'adopter des textes plus
efficace et plus en adéquation avec les
réalités du pays tes textes qui
permettront aux françaises et aux
français de se projeter des textes qui
répondent à leurs situations
particulières et qui leur donne
collectivement confiance en leur avenir
je vais en citer deux le premier c'est
celui qui portera les mesures pour
garantir le pouvoir d'achat des français
ce projet est très attendue par nos
concitoyens ils portent une exigence
d'efficacité mais aussi de solidarité
nous ne sommes pas tous égaux face au
poids de l'inflation et il nous
reviendra de nous assurer que les
mesures que nous porterons répondront
bien à chacune des situations et
atteindront réellement leur cible mais
c'est aussi avec ce texte que nous
pourrons montrer notre capacité à
effectuer des compromis
j'entends que certains disent déjà ici
qu'il ne le voterons pas et pourtant
personne sur ses bancs estime qu'il ne
faut pas répondre à l'urgence ou qu'il
faudrait laisser faire personne n'a
intérêt ou blocage c'est pourquoi je
m'adresse solennellement à toutes les
bonnes volontés de cet hémicycle avec ce
texte nous pourrons montrer aux
françaises et aux français que nous
avons entendu leur message
avec ce texte nous pourrons agir agir
vite et fort pour améliorer leur vie
quotidienne
pour revaloriser les minima sociaux la
prime d'activité et les pensions de
retraite les allocations familiales pour
instaurer un bouclier sur les loyers et
limiter leurs housses pour que chacun
ait accès à une alimentation de qualité
sans que jamais cela ne se fasse au
détriment de ceux qui nous nourrissent
sur ce texte madame la première ministre
nous serons pour le gouvernement des
partenaires loyaux et positif ouvert à
la discussion et aux améliorations de
nos collègues des autres groupes
politiques dans le cadre de l'engagement
que nous avons pris devant nos
concitoyens
ce qui vaut pour les projets de loi doit
également valoir pour les initiatives
parlementaires
ce sont elles qui disent notre identité
qui nous forge dans cette enceinte et
auprès des français alors oui un grand
oui nous inscrirons le droit à l'image
est dans notre constitution
les droits des femmes ne sont pas un
fonds de commerce pas plus qu'il ne
serait un sujet et accessoires ceux qui
disent que nous avons le temps
d'attendre se trompent d'autres
démocraties l'on pense et qui voit
aujourd'hui des femmes risquent 15 ans
d'emprisonnement si elles ont recours à
leurs libertés fondamentales ou encore
une petite fille américaine de dix ans
dix ans condamnés à aller au bout d'une
grossesse conséquente d'un viol nous
avons les moyens d'agir alors nous
agirons nous protégerons les femmes
maintenant et pour demain pour notre
pays et pour le message que notre pays
en voie pour les femmes du monde entier
nous aurons ainsi l'occasion d'engager
ensemble dans une logique transpartisane
une modification constitutionnelle par
la voie de l'initiative parlementaire ce
serait une première depuis 1958 c'est
une prérogative que la constitution un
frau parlement saisissons la
loyaux et fidèles au président de la
république et aux projets qui nous a
conduits ou reconduits ici certains nous
diront soumis cela ne nous empêchera pas
de réaffirmer notre loyauté et notre
fidélité loin des caricatures
libres libres de porter nos combats
politiques et de nouvelles conquêtes
sociales pour les français on nous dira
a franchi cela ne nous empêchera pas
d'initier de proposer fidèle au mandat
que les français nous ont confié nous
l'avons déjà fait sans jamais sombrer
dans la démagogie et croyant résolument
au rassemblement et au dépassement
politique c'est ce chemin de crête
c'est en même temps du temps
parlementaire que nous emprunterons
déterminé et serein avec le groupe que
j'ai déjà désormais l'honneur de
présider gens c'est l'exigence et la
complexité gens c'est surtout la
nécessité pour que les français nous
jugent utile pour eux et pour leurs
enfants je le redis un président fort et
une assemblée forte voilà ce que les
français ont choisi
mes chers collègues j'ai commencé ce
propos par notre constitution je veux y
revenir pour conclure parce qu'il était
en fait incontestable s'ils perdent leur
vote du 19 juin les français ont sans
doute exprimé des attentes fortes les
impatiences des colère aussi ils ont
aussi clairement choisi de ne pas
changer de république en 1967 le
président de gaulle déclarait un jour
viendra sans doute où notre constitution
avec tout ce qu'elle implique sera
devenu comme notre seconde nature il
nous appartient aujourd'hui par notre
sens des responsabilités
par la pratique de notre mandat de lui
donner raison car cela répond non
seulement à nos convictions mais aussi
mais surtout au verdict des urnes
démontré que collectivement nous sommes
capables de trouver dans notre texte
fondamental les ressources pour que la
france continue d'avancer voilà ce à
quoi nous sommes prêts au sein de notre
groupe claire sur le cadre général qui
est celui de la cohérence du projet du
président élu par les français en avril
dernier et que nous nous sommes engagés
à contribuer à concrétiser
claire sur les compromis que nous sommes
disposés à construire avec toutes celles
et tous ceux qui partageaient les
valeurs républicaines qui nous anime
quels que soient les désaccords
politiques qui peuvent nous distinguer
par ailleurs claire et fidèle à l'esprit
des femmes qui nous guide comme ce fut
le cas de ruth bader ginsburg à la cour
suprême lutte et lutter pour les choses
qui vous tiennent à coeur mais faites-le
d'une manière qui amènera d'autres
personnes à vous rejoindre et claire
éclaire enfin madame la première
ministre sur le soutien que nous vous
apportons ainsi qu'à votre gouvernement
[Applaudissements]